our panelist Catherine Marshall who has
had I think more than four decades of
experience with humanitarian work we're
all much we all started we were just
children two or three years old but she
is a senior fellow at Georgetown
University's Berkeley center for
religion and world affairs and a
Georgetown visiting professor she's also
executive director of the world faiths
development dialogue which I understand
you were engaged in perhaps if not
launching definitely you're there at the
beginning but before that she had a
career with the World Bank and there she
worked for many years and then led the
World Bank's faith in ethics work
through the first decade of this century
and her books include development in
faith where mind heart and soul worked
together and I loved the fact that you
also in your article in reflections
Catherine talked about the bottom line
questions why should we care what can we
do about it what is our responsibility
and you gave us reasons to care not only
the reasons based on faith and on
compassion but also the practical
reasons for why we need to care and act
in our own self-interest on behalf of
the poor and then you talked about the
complexities and it is not simple so I
don't know how much of that you are
going to share with us again but I
commend all of you to read Katherine's
article we're happy to have you here
thank you well senator Coons has said
almost everything that I would like to
say but there there are a few points
that I think we should highlight the
first that i was struck when my son who
I think was 10 at the time challenged me
when I was speaking and saying that we
can achieve a world without poverty we
have the resources we have the know-how
we have the examples and he said you
don't really believe that do you but I
believe it with all my heart that we can
and because we can
we have the obligation to do something
about it it's a very different situation
from most of world history where poverty
was the norm but in country after
country we've seen transformations in in
a lifetime in a career so I think that
first point is one that people don't
believe that like my 10 year old son at
the time they don't fully accept that
this is something it's a transformation
that is that is our gift but is also our
obligation and our responsibility the
second thought and you you cautioned us
against using statistics and I will want
to pick up simply on two of the numbers
not the billions that we quote all the
time but the 20,000 children who die
every day and one other number that I
never can get away from because of
personal experience which is that a
woman is two thousand times more likely
to die in nazare in childbirth than she
is in Scandinavia and actually it's
rather sad that that number is not an
american number because scandinavia does
a lot better than the United States but
apart from the raw injustice of these
deaths I was scanning the newspapers
coming back from a trip there's no
mention of these deaths the women who
died the children who die they die the
people who died of AIDS die die hiding
almost in shame and yet one of the joys
of our society is that we more in every
death we we value when we treasure every
person and somehow that sense the it's
one of the things that's most
frustrating for people who work in
development is how how absent how
invisible these problems seem to be in
everyday life so I think that's one of
the challenges for all of us apart from
believing that it's possible to find
ways to communicate both the hope and
the injustice the raw in Jaws
this reading about what's happening in
North Africa and talking to people there
are I think some some important messages
for us first we live in a different
world and it's an interconnected world
that's a world that's connected not only
by cell phones and computers it's
connected by ideas and by visions and
the hopes that those young people have
are so similar to the hopes of young
people at our universities they are the
hopes for a job for respect for decency
they are but they are also impatient as
our young people are impatient and I
think that that's something we should
never forget but one thing that this
surprise revolution calls us to I think
as much as anything is a much more
intelligent and professional analysis of
what religion means in this because
religion is absolutely a vital part we
should never think that because it's not
completely visible that it's not a
fundamental part of these societies that
are profoundly religious so I think that
understanding we've been caught off
guard and not understanding the
religious nature and we need a
professional a compassionate and a sober
understanding of where religion fits my
last comment I'm going to tell you just
about one of the thousands of people
that I've worked with over the years
ayesha at jenna is a remarkable
courageous Moroccan woman she won the
Opus prize which is given for people to
buy a Minnesota foundation that's
looking for the next Mother Teresa but
she has worked for 40 years with the
people who are at the very bottom of
Morocco's society and of society across
many parts of the world including Africa
who are young unmarried mothers and she
has for 40 years battled to change the
laws that
have discriminated against women to put
women's issues into the light and to
help one by one these girls but one of
her comments echoes a little bit what I
was saying about the challenges that we
face talking to her she talks time and
time again about the knife edge we're on
the knife edge we're between hope and
great danger and if we do not act if we
act wrong if we make mistakes if we're
clumsy she's talking about herself if i
push too hard in the wrong place or if i
miss a chance we're we're facing
exciting possibilities but also a very
dangerous world a very interconnected
world and we need to keep the courageous
fighters the women and the children
always at the center of our minds quite
a challenge thank you very much
Catherine